y
[Música]
falleció de los 87 años ruth báder
ginsburg jueza de la corte suprema de
eeuu la notable arbey y luchó sus
últimos días contra un cáncer de
páncreas y será recordada por su férrea
defensa por la igualdad de género a
menos de dos meses de las elecciones los
republicanos han prometido votar para
confirmar a quién donald trump no vine
para reemplazarla lo que augura una
nueva batalla política en el capitolio
tenemos análisis
el congreso de perú votó contra la
destitución del presidente de martín
vizcarra en un juicio político en el que
la oposición mayoría en el legislativo
se quedó corta en sus acusaciones de
incapacidad moral en su discurso de
defensa del mandatario dijo que el país
no debería distraerse de sus verdaderos
desafíos como 'el hobbit' 19
y en tailandia miles de personas se
manifiestan en contra del gobierno del
primer ministro prayudh chanocha al
mismo tiempo que piden limitar el poder
de la monarquía y acabar con la ley de
lesa majestad que exige prisión a
personas que sean declaradas culpables
de difamar a la institución real
comienza esta mañana de sábado y también
las noticias en france 24 mi nombre es
ángela gómez bienvenidos hay luto en
eeuu por el fallecimiento de la jueza de
la corte suprema ruth báder ginsburg
tras repetidas batallas contra el cáncer
conocida como la notable arbey y dada su
incansable lucha por la igualdad de
derechos para las mujeres fue una
potente voz liberal en la mayor corte
del país y deja libre un puesto
vitalicio para el que donald trump o
podría nominar a un tercer magistrado
esto desataría una férrea batalla entre
republicanos y demócratas en el congreso
y tendría un profundo impacto en las
elecciones de noviembre veamos la
historia de vida de la jueza ginsburg
en la izquierda estadounidense ha
perdido a su icono wef by the game break
una pionera en la defensa de los
derechos de la mujer murió este viernes
después de luchar contra 5 episodios de
cáncer a lo largo de su vida esta jueza
de la corte suprema de eeuu puso una
larga carrera legal impulsada por sus
propias luchas como mujer en una
profesión dominada por hombres en la
facultad de derecho de harvard fue una
de las nueve mujeres de una clase de 500
estudiantes después de graduarse de
columbia como la mejor de su año todavía
se enfrentó a dificultades para
encontrar trabajo ya que los jueces
federales no querían contratar mujeres
en 1970 fundó la primera revista
jurídica dedicada exclusivamente a los
derechos de la mujer
dos años después ayudó a lanzar una
sección similar dentro de la poderosa
unión americana de libertades civiles y
para 1974 el organismo había participado
en más de 300 demandas por
discriminación de género así ginsburg se
ganó una reputación con su trabajo
pero constante favoreciendo las batallas
ganables por encima de los casos
llamativos en 1994 fue nominada a la
corte suprema por bill clinton
convirtiéndola en la segunda mujer en
servir en el máximo órgano judicial de
eeuu allí continuó defendiendo los
derechos de las mujeres con sentencias
sobre temas controversiales como el
aborto el matrimonio entre personas del
mismo sexo y la inmigración era
reconocida por ser una gran disidente
del gobierno de camps y cuando hablaba
de su visión de la ley durante discursos
en todo el país siempre era recibida con
ovaciones cuando la gente le preguntaba
cuántos de los nueve escaños del
tribunal debían ocupar mujeres ella
siempre daba la misma respuesta
wendy dice cuando crees que habrá
suficiente
es obvio cuando haya 9
su baja estatura combinada con su
rechazo a dejarse intimidar la hizo
ascender al estatus de ícono de la
cultura pop en una generación mucho más
joven
la popular magistrada del más alto
tribunal del país era venerada por los
progresistas y odiada por los
conservadores
la nominación de donald trump de dos
jueces de la corte suprema cambió el
balance de la corte de cinco a cuatro
por los conservadores el fallecimiento
de ginsberg podría reforzar la tendencia
conservadora en la entidad
vamos a discutir las implicaciones
después de la muerte de la jueza
ginsburg y por eso nos acompaña en el
estudio andrés espinal jefe de redacción
de france 24 en español andrés buenos
días para usted y comenzó preguntándole
cuáles han sido las implicaciones o las
reacciones de los republicanos y los
demócratas después del anuncio del
fallecimiento de harvey y expliquen los
cuales la batalla política que se
avecina bueno tanto republicanos como
demócratas están lamentando la muerte de
esta persona pues de esta jueza que era
considerada una pionera y una defensora
de los derechos de la mujer pero esto ha
tomado rápidamente un aspecto político
después de que el líder de la mayoría
republicana del senado mitch mcconnell
confirmara que va a haber un voto
justamente para confirmar a la persona
que donald trump designe para reemplazar
a arbey y entonces por otro lado los
demócratas principalmente el candidato a
joe biden están pidiendo que primero
haya una elección y que sea el
presidente el encargado de designar a
ese reemplazo entonces esto hace eco de
un caso del año 2016 cuando el juez de
merik garland que fue nominado por
barack obama fue bloqueado por los
republicanos en el senado justamente
porque decían que
país estaba en un año electoral y que
había que esperar la voluntad del pueblo
ahora la batalla va a consistir
básicamente en los unos demócratas
tratando de dilatar este proceso de
confirmación y los republicanos tratando
de llevarlo por la vía expresa bueno y
más allá de si lo dilatan o no el
promedio en el que se toman estas
elecciones son 72 días y recordemos que
son menos de dos meses antes de las
elecciones presidenciales porque es
andrés es tan importante el reemplazo de
la jueza y qué implicaciones va a tener
esto para la carrera presidencial
bueno pues tenemos que recordar que la
corte suprema en este antes de la muerte
de ruth báder ginsburg se consideraba
que había cuatro jueces de corte liberal
cuatro de corte conservador más el
presidente de la corte que es john
roberts que también es conservador
entonces se consideraba que había una
inclinación de cinco a cuatro a favor de
los conservadores si donald trump llega
a nominar y a poner a un tercer juez en
esa corte significa que ese
desequilibrio pasa a ser de 6 a 3 y eso
despierta el interés de todos los
votantes tanto republicanos como
demócratas porque muchos consideran que
hay demasiado en juego se cree que está
en juego el tema del derecho al aborto
el cambio
los límites del poder del ejecutivo la
segunda enmienda entonces básicamente
estamos en un contexto en el que además
de unas protestas muy fuertes por el
tema racial en eeuu de una pandemia que
se ha llevado a casi 200.000 personas y
de una crisis de empleo ahora la corte
suprema- pasa a ocupar un rol central en
esta carrera donde donald trump por un
lado dice que tiene una lista de jueces
muy conservadores y para el otro lado yo
vaivén no tiene una lista pero dice que
si se le da la oportunidad pondría la
primera mujer afroamericana en el cargo
entonces nos enfrentamos a un tema de
extrema polarización gracias a andrés y
continuamos con más noticias en américa
latina' perú el presidente martín
vizcarra es el libro de la destitución
tras la votación de juicio político en
el legislativo al que fue sometido bajo
la acusación de incapacidad moral por
supuestos contratos turbios en el
gobierno la oposición que domina el
congreso emitió 32 de los 87 votos
requeridos para removerlo del cargo a 10
meses de que termine el mandato en su
discurso de defensa de aseguró que el
país no debería distraerse del desafío
real la pandemia
los grandes desafíos del perú nos exigen
actuar con sensatez y responsabilidad
sigamos trabajando todos unidos por lo
que realmente importa a los peruanos la
lucha contra la pandemia la reactivación
económica el fortalecimiento de la
democracia el combate a la corrupción
para mejorar la calidad de vida de
quienes lo necesitan y miles de jóvenes
se manifiesta en este fin de semana en
bangkok para exigir reformas en la
constitución y mayor control sobre la
monarquía entre otras reivindicaciones
está la renuncia del primer ministro
veamos
las multitudes se abarrotan frente a las
puertas de este campus de bangkok
las cadenas finalmente ceden y cientos
de manifestantes entran en el recinto
universitario
debemos recuperar nuestra democracia
nuestra lucha no debe ser en vano todos
hacen el mismo gesto tres dedos
levantados en el aire la señal de la
unión de los opositores a quienes
ostentan el poder tailandés la mayoría
de los manifestantes son estudiantes han
estado marchando casi a diario desde
este verano para exigir más democracia
en el país
debe haber transparencia debemos tener
el derecho de saber lo que pasa en
nuestro país y no solo recibir órdenes
de nuestros líderes
holly entre las reivindicaciones de este
movimiento prodemocrático el fin del
acoso a los opositores políticos la
disolución del parlamento la dimisión
del primer ministro pero también la
revisión de la constitución de 2017
redactada cuando la junta militar estaba
en el poder parte de este movimiento
también ataca a la monarquía y condena
la interferencia del rey en los asuntos
políticos algo nunca antes visto en este
país donde el crimen de lesa majestad se
castiga con 3 hasta 15 años de cárcel
los activistas prodemocracia
en el domingo a la casa de gobierno para
presentar sus demandas esperan organizar
la mayor manifestación desde el golpe de
estado de 2014
hasta aquí el informativo pero seguimos
en france 24 que desde con nosotros
[Música]